okay so i know that we haven't really
talked much about boba fett and a lot of
that's because boba fett those episodes
have been like ketchup at restaurants
right it takes forever for anything to
come out and when it does hardly
anything comes out at all so i you know
episode number six was just a great
episode episode number five was good but
it was like i mean like where's boba
fett but episode number six was
phenomenal so we're gonna have spoilers
in this episode this this video so just
be aware right we're gonna have spoilers
in this first things first i just want
to kind of cover a couple things right
talk about a couple things one
i loved that we got to see the training
of grogu at the hands of luke skywalker
my biggest fear was that when luke took
grogu away
at the end of at the end of the last
season of the mandalorian that we
wouldn't really even get to see his
training per se that they were possibly
going to write him out or his training
would just kind of get small little
glimpses and would basically happen off
panel or i'm sorry off screen
like this episode episode 6 was like 90
grogu being trained and it was great to
see because luke skywalker being a jedi
master in training at padawan i mean
he's not very good at it right like so
if any of you guys are familiar with the
jedi lore and you're familiar with
effective jedi masters versus
ineffective jedi masters
looks kind of bad at his job but not all
of it is necessarily luke skywalker's
fault and we'll talk about you know why
we are really the most significant thing
uh you know as we get towards the end of
this as we get towards the end of this
video but overall um i love the feeling
of the episode uh of course it didn't
necessarily feel like a boba fett
episode which seems to be kind of a
common trend between last episode and
this episode
because boba fett is hardly ever in it
but i think that's kind of a good thing
and the reason why is because seeing
boba fed and what he's doing is not
particularly interesting but what's
really cool about what's going on in the
last episode in this episode is it's
marshalling forces right like the whole
spice cartels and all that kind of stuff
right basically setting up tatooine as
what is in effect just a giant beach
head in the war against like the spice
cartels right like trying to turn
tattooing into place where it's no
longer like a smuggling hub right where
it's no longer a place where people
basically run what is the equivalent of
drugs in the star wars universe uh and
keeping it is kind of a safe haven right
the fact that boba fett is coming from
the perspective that people like jabba
the hutt ran their empires out of fear
where he's looking more towards the
direction of like reunification bringing
in people that he knows it's cool to see
it all basically consolidate down
because i feel like going into the new
season of the mandalorian only one of
two things is going to happen right that
either well i guess it only makes sense
one of two things going to happen that
either the mandalorian is going to focus
on the story of mando following the
events of boba fett or it's gonna
continue the story of boba fett but from
the perspective of the mandalorian
largely outside of boba fett himself or
what he was doing during that time to
see these shows basically crossing over
i love the idea but i love that concept
having said that and really because so
much emphasis here was really put on
grogu and his training here's the thing
to understand so once you get to the end
of the episode of boba fett a choice is
given to grogu right that the gift that
was given to him from the mandalorian
who of course he was not allowed to see
because of the idea of like attachment
and it would basically it would it would
really lead to grogu kind of regressing
and desiring for the mandalorian to come
back as opposed to being able to move on
um that the choice was either the
lightsaber or the armor and that if he
chose the armor that of course that
would lead to him basically falling back
down onto the path of wanting to see the
mandalorian giving in to attachment
versus the lightsaber which would
symbolize him moving beyond attachment
but here's a funny thing i never agreed
with the philosophy of the jedi that
like attachment was a bad thing the jedi
themselves don't necessarily shun love
and that's one thing that i want to make
clear here right they don't really shun
love and in fact the perspective of love
from jedi themselves isn't really a
romantic love but more of a love of all
things right everything has value
everything has worth we should care
about everything in existence as if it's
our brothers and sisters right but the
idea of like romantic love right
procreating different things like that
that was largely shunned that's the
reason why like anakin and padme kept
the relationship a secret from the jedi
council because if they knew that that
anakin was knocking boots with padme
they'd be like this is a problem and the
reason why is because the jedi largely
believe that like love leads to passion
and passion is what sends you down the
dark side but love inevitably leads to
that right it's a very dogmatic and very
absolute perspective but if any of you
guys are familiar with the star wars
mythos and while i'm not an expert in
star wars um i will say i'm pretty
familiar with jolie bendo so julie bendo
both in the original star wars knight to
the old republic and in the in the
expanded universe as a larger whole he
was what you would call a gray jedi so
gray jedi are basically jedi who haven't
fallen to the dark side but they don't
ally themselves with the jedi council on
the light side they kind of do their own
thing right like they beat to their own
drum is really how it works and a lot of
it's because as time progresses for one
reason or another they become
disillusioned with the jedi council and
its way of doing things but they don't
have a desire to fall to the dark side
they just kind of go out and and follow
their own thing now when it came to the
idea of like love and attachment and
things like that
julie bendo had a really really cool
quote where he said the jedi with their
damnable sense of overcaution would tell
you love is something to avoid
thankfully anyone who's even partially
alive knows that's not true love does
not lead to the dark side passion can
lead to rage and fear and can be
controlled but passion is not the same
thing is love controlling your passions
while being in love that's what they
should teach you to beware but love
itself will save you
not condemn you and so it's really
interesting here because like if we use
the example of anakin skywalker right
and we say okay anakin skywalker his
path to falling down the dark side you
could argue that it was in the beginning
like when he was basically too old to be
trained uh he had too much strong
familial ties to his mom and by and
large he felt ripped away he didn't
fully understand what was going on but
then when his mother died while she was
being held captive by the sand people
that anakin gave over to rage that was
his first real time experiencing the
significant loss of a loved one not in
the sense that like he had left his mom
but in the sense that his mom was gone
and there was no conceivable way to get
her back she was dead and so when the
time came that he had visions of padme
dying the feelings of his mother dying
resurfaced and in turn his desire was to
save padme the failing of the jedi
council was to say no you have to leave
those attachments behind azamos is
saying that sometimes familial
attachments are actually a source of
strength because they keep you on the
path of understanding what matters the
most that was always my perspective now
it is possible to be corrupted but the
corruption of anakin was the failure of
the jedi to basically provide him with
an out to say we understand the tie that
you have to your mom and trying to pull
him away from that was the failing
instead it should have been something
that was embraced let's launch some kind
of rescue to save your mom's life
because i have to believe that anakin's
path would have been starkly different
had his mother survived again just kind
of my perspective here so luke
skywalker's handling in the way he
trains uh grogu is in a lot of ways the
way that like parents raise their kids
you can only raise your kids based on
how you were raised you can do a little
bit of research and do some poking
around and different things like that
but the gut instincts you have will come
from what you were taught and so in a
lot of ways a child can seemingly only
ever be as capable as their parents were
and raising a child of their own of
course that kind of assumes you don't
necessarily do the leg work but the
important thing here is that luke is
training grogu based on how he was
trained through a combination of obi-wan
kenobi and yoda but one of the things
that we know is that luke skywalker's
training was incomplete that he left
yoda during the events of empire strikes
back and yoda even said if you leave now
and you go to save your friends your
your training will be incomplete you
could potentially save them right but
the choice you have to learn to make as
a jedi is between your friends between
attachments or going through and and
becoming like a full-on jedi right
embracing the jedi way the jedi code and
so it's interesting because when you
look at this
the the potential exists here
that grogu could fall to the dark side
because one thing we don't have an
answer to is what happened between the
time that luke has seemingly taken on
grogu as a padawan and like the knights
of ren right like was grogu around was
he killed by the knights of ren was he
on the other side of the galaxy when
that happened because he was old enough
that he kind of moved on right like one
of the things that luke said in this
episode is that uh if he decides to go
the path of the jedi he may never see
the mandalorian again because what would
amount to a very short amount of time in
in grogu's life right what we would
attribute to be you know our teenage
years would in effect for him be like a
hundred years potentially it would be
much much longer than the lifespan of
the mandalorians so quite literally he
could outlive the mandalorian in the
time he's training to become a jedi and
so in that way it could be entirely
possible that he could experience the
same kind of loss in the way that anna
can experience the loss of his mom and
the inability to bring the mandalorian
back and then fall to the dark side in
that way the other part of this is he
could fall to the dark side because he's
unable to let go of the mandalorian
because there's possibly anger there
over the fact that he's being made to
make a choice in the first place right
that why can't he simply just have both
and so it's a really really interesting
concept the the episode overall was was
just great it was phenomenal right i
absolutely loved it the duel in the
desert between timothy oliphant and what
was basically a hired gun that was legit
and i absolutely loved that like it
reminded me of like the man with no name
trilogy right like the old clint
eastwood movies what was it a fistful of
dollars a few dollars more and then the
good the bad and the ugly like it was it
was great right it was like it was like
clint eastwood lee van cleef you know
let red go it was one of those those
just great moments right it was just a
great scene as quick as it was i love
that we got to see timothy alla fan
again and i loved the opening scene
right where like he sees those guys out
in the desert who are trading spice and
like what is it he says it's something
to the effect of like think about it
right like be sure you want to do this
right he like guns three of them down
leave the last one for dead and it's
just like go tell your guys
tatooine is off limits right like this
this place is off limits to them which
of course leads to the duel in the
desert in the first place uh i mean it's
it's one of those cool things you know
it reminds me of like when they blow up
the cantina and everything it reminds me
of when michael corleone was taking care
of all family business at the end of the
godfather but do you guys remember that
i don't know how many of you guys ever
saw godfather but like at the end of
that movie michael corleone basically
has all the other heads of the five
families killed right so like strategy
bartsini mo green like all those guys
right just has them all executed right
they're all basically taken out so he's
the only mob boss in like new york new
jersey and controlling the mob as it
exists in america at that point in time
at least on the italian side right that
was of course you know way after salaza
when like he killed him in the pizza
shop like that was nuts it was just a
ridiculously amazing scene but
nonetheless right it feels a lot like
that like it's just mob warfare right
these guys show up they blow up the
cantina and we're kind of left to assume
nobody survived that whole ordeal that
it's just like this is how it starts the
tatooine is basically descending into
all-out war and i am so excited to see
how that happens it kind of sucks and it
took five episodes to get to this point
but i also understand why it did because
if this had happened like three episodes
in it wouldn't quite have the same
impact right boba fett is definitely a
slow build over the course of the show
it's definitely taking its time to get
us to this point where things are
popping off but the great thing is that
now that we're here there's a lot of
opportunity so while i couldn't
necessarily appreciate the slow burn of
boba fett when it first launched i can
absolutely appreciate it now i am i am
on board this episode was great i
absolutely loved it so yeah let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
right again we haven't really covered
boba fett because honestly it was just
it was boring as hell up to this point
but uh but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section
let me know how you guys enjoyed this
episode and yeah i will catch you all
later peace